let's jump to a less uh uh philosophical
but
uh interesting story about someone
bothering somebody
this is this is this is nuts you guys
ready for this nike sue's rapper lil nas
x over satan shoes that have real blood
in the souls the shoes which contain a
drop of human blood in the soil when on
sale monday for one thousand eighteen
dollars per pair
they say the shoes are unofficial
designs of nike's trademark air max 97
design
though the shoe companies that is not
involved with the creation of the shoe
they contain a drop of human blood in
the soul and when on sale monday
only 666 pairs were made available and
all were sold out shortly after going on
sale
the shoes drew plenty of high profile
critics including south dakota governor
christie gnome
and former clemson university
quarterback trevor lawrence our kids are
being told
this kind of product is is not not only
okay
it's exclusive gnome tweeted the artist
responded by writing
you're a whole governor and you on here
tweeting about some damn shoes do your
job
lil nas axe is not named a defendant in
nike's lawsuit
not named interesting shortly after the
lawsuit was announced he posted a tweet
showing a homeless squidward from
spongebob squarepants
begging for change and it says me after
the nike lawsuit
and there's a homeless squidward i
thought that was funny
i thought that was funny nike filed a
trademark infringement and delusion
complaint against
msch mischief mschf today
related to satan's shoes quote we don't
have further details to share on pending
legal matters however we can tell you we
do not have a relationship with lil nas
x or mischief the satan's shoes were
produced without nike's approval or
authorization
and nike is in no way connected with his
project
first of all that tweet with the
squidward thing that was legit that was
funny
uh how did he decide like how did how
was he able to make a nike shoe
without nike's approval that's that's
just not they're customs they're not
actually by nike but isn't that
infringement of some sort like you would
think but it seems like they
i mean there's a huge culture i've been
learning this last two days because i'm
in a twitter worth
nazis fans right now but i got ratio to
hell
myself but uh um
there's this like huge subculture of
people who customize
sneakers and apparently it's a really
big deal and nike normally doesn't
enforce copyright i guess
but because this one has caused so much
blow back
i think they had no choice really i
don't care about this shoe
this i actually think it's kind of funny
he dripped blood in the shoes and then
resold them is that what it is
i think it's his blood i really want to
know whose blood it is
i mean look i think it's weird but i
think if somebody wants to make a weird
shoe and sell it and they like
oh i'm saying yeah but whatever nike
design on it the logo
yeah okay my issue with it is not
the troll game like i respect his troll
game he's he got me
ratioed real hard like i got ratio to
hell
like it was crazy i have to give him
props for that at least
you know troll respects troll i guess
but um my only issue with anything that
he's done
is the fact that in january he was doing
interviews with npr
bragging about how children are his fan
base he was doing videos with elmo
he wrote a children's book he performed
in an
elementary school gym like he i think
there was a kids bop version
of country roads or whatever song
called i mean he he really went out of
his way to market to children which is a
smart thing to do because children are
a huge consumer base and parents are
going to spend money on their kids all
the time and
yeah it's smart i think he i think i'm
glad he did
but the problem is you can't brand
yourself
i mean i think that the lyrics to old
town wrote are questionable anyway and
parents probably shouldn't have been
letting their kids listen to it but you
know after the children's book and the
npr interview and
during concert in roblox he's branded
himself as somebody that is safe for
children
so this is the best thing he could have
done with the satan shoe with the blood
in it
because now parents are going to be like
whoa maybe i shouldn't have my kid
following this if they catch it on time
i mean as a parent
i have a really difficult time with it
because my daughter wants to watch
people playing video games and stuff and
so she'll
i'll be watching a video game channel
with her and it'll seem very wholesome
and it'll be great
for weeks and then all of a sudden
they'll start talking about like
some insane cult blue and on nonsense or
you know saying that there's 170 genders
or whatever the hell
and and it's hard to keep up with it
especially on youtube and stuff like
that but even with like disney channel
and nickelodeon
it's very hard right now to find like
wholesome content that you can trust and
i
and i know parents work and there's all
kinds of stuff going on you can't always
keep up
this guy built a reputation that he was
safe for children
and then he came out with a video where
he's pole dancing to hell
and then giving a lap dance to satan
you can't really blame parents for being
upset with this one
i'm just saying by doing this and
generating the controversy
it's like sending a flare up into the
air so that parents can see it and maybe
now realize he's not so safe for kids
right which is why people are calling it
out right everybody's like you're trying
to get them canceled and
you know all this stuff and first it's
like yeah kind of because like i firmly
believe that we should be canceling the
left back
but also it's more about
making sure that parents see it you want
parents to know not to let their kids
watch this
and so by putting articles up on gateway
pundit that are getting you know
hundreds of thousands of views
maybe some parents will be like oh crap
my kid really likes this i better watch
out
absolutely and i think that's important
it kind of reminds me of i think it's
i think it's a family guy joke where
they give you know one of the kids like
stewie
a children's video on youtube and
they're like hi kids let's learn the
abcs
and then like the parent walks away and
they're like abc all right your parents
gone good go into mommy's purse get her
credit card
now go to this website yeah yeah it's
like are they gone all right let's do
this
there's a lot of jokes like that i just
think i mean for one again i'll stress
his troll game's on point and so i look
at what he's doing as like screwing the
status quo it's punk rock man
and i was i was thinking about that like
where's where's
the you know we we talked about eminem's
song cancel me or something i think it's
called i don't know without me
no no no no it's like a new one they're
trying to make it i think he's so dorky
yeah it's not very good but we talked
about that song without me
uh you guys remember that song i love
that song from like 2002.
the whole song makes no sense oh right
no
without taking a minute real slim shady
it's called without me
yeah and the whole song is about
cultural references
at the time he's literally just talking
smack
and being extremely offensive i don't
think anybody would make anything like
that
and popularize it on tv or in movies the
way they did because he literally makes
disparaging remarks about christina
aguilera you know surfacing
two guys from that era in the song and
that song's got a billion views
i'm just thinking about this stuff like
where are the people who are like i'm
going to screw with the system to like
my utmost
like the to the maximum possible level
and just tell everyone to go
shove it you can't do anything about it
i mean this isn't new though we had
marilyn manson we've had all this stuff
before it's not new it's just the only
thing that's different
is yeah he looked this is literally two
months ago it's not like we're talking
about like miley cyrus where she was a
child star
and then grew up and started making
content that was more geared for adults
i know people still get mad about that
but that bothers me less
this was literally in january he's
putting out children's books he's going
on npr talking about how he wants to
appeal to children
or how he likes that he appeals to
children
and it was a marketing strategy children
are a huge
huge product consumer base like what how
old of children
i mean the average age for roblox
concert is
under 13 like the average roblox users
under 13 my daughter uses it all the
time
um he did a video with elmo i mean
that's
geared towards toddlers sesame street
went like full on racist apparently
anyway so elmo
elmo got to learn about why martin
luther king jr was wrong in one of the
weirdest segments i've ever seen sesame
street do it's amazing
yeah so uh sesame street introduces two
new black puppets
abcs of racial literacy and apparently
these characters are saying like the
color of their skin is a very important
aspect of who they are
all right fine i'm being a bit
hyperbolic when i say they they learn
about why my
thing was wrong it's not literally what
they're saying i'm sure martin luther
king jr thought
there was relevancy to the color of skin
because of racism they say
first revealed on march 24th by sesame
workshop the non-profit organization
responsible for the long-running
children's show production abc's of
racial literacy resource
is designed to help families celebrate
their own unique identities
and answer children's tough questions
about race and racism
apparently in this like sesame street
segment
he asks them why they're like black and
they explain their race and all that
stuff
the issue i take with it is that while i
certainly think color blindness as a
general term
is probably not a good thing we do want
to recognize racism exists and that
people are treated poorly
you want to treat people as equals
without consideration of their race
the problem is i guess many people are
saying no you should give me positive
discrimination
because of past discrimination that's
ibro max kennedy's like thought process
so sure this dude's doing videos with
elmo i'm not sure elmo or something
people want to have their kids watch
but you know what happens i bet a lot of
millennial parents are like i used to
watch sesame street
you should watch sesame street too and
their kid comes in one day one day like
a seven-year-old goes to their mom and
starts preaching about racial
segregation and the mom's going to be
like
what and it's just happened to me like
recently
and it's shocking like i am almost a
helicopter parent about what my daughter
sees
what she does on the internet i don't
allow her to be on the internet if i'm
not in the room
like i am kind of kind of a bit much
about this
but but i was watching we went on
vacation we don't have cable at my house
we just watched like streaming services
but we're on vacation we're in the hotel
room and i put on the disney channel
and we're just watching a show that
we've watched a million times old show
so it's not
you know over the top but a commercial
came on talking about like the
impeachment and how
he's not necessary just because he was
found not guilty doesn't mean he didn't
do something wrong
and then black lives matter commercials
and all this stuff and i'm sitting there
i'm like
when i was little disney it was
wholesome as heck like and so i
i implicitly like i trust disney channel
and nickelodeon and stuff because when i
was a kid it was like people getting
slimed and stuff
they weren't talking about politics they
weren't talking about this stuff wow
when i was a kid all that stuff i wanted
to do the opposite of
you know what i mean like when we would
see those commercials about like
well at least maybe it's growing up in
the south side of chicago where they're
like you know stay out of gangs kids and
don't do drugs like all of my friends
were like hmm
i think i'm gonna go do those things
what are those yeah what are those
yeah apparently there was like i guess
in some instances the dare program which
was telling kids not to do drugs
just taught them how to do drugs it's
like don't put it in your mouth and
light it with a layer and then
suck it in don't do that don't inhale
afterwards
yeah so we just watched uh man of the
year just like as a side
as an aside real quick have you seen men
of the year no 2006 robin williams
so andreas was telling us he's a dude
who hangs out here
uh he was telling us that there's a
scene where robin williams says cough
coffee coffee over and over again he
doesn't but we watched the film
it's about a media personality supposed
to be like jon stewart
and people are like why don't you run
for president he does and then he wins
it's the craziest thing you got to watch
it you got to see this
you know why you know why you got to
watch it no it was like watching
someone predicted donald trump robin
williams plays
a misogynistic anti-semitic comedian and
i don't mean that in the literal sense
i mean that at the time that comedy was
considered appropriate and good and
everyone loved it on the left
so when he makes jokes about women and
jews and illegal aliens
everyone's laughing and so he actually
says he gets like 10
in the polls there's one scene where
basically
he's debating the other two presidents
because his poll numbers are so well
and then he's like they want to add a
constitutional amendment so you can't
burn the american flag
it's a distraction because four million
illegal aliens just crossed our border
robin williams said that wow and i was
like this is crazy and then
he ends up winning i'm gonna spoil the
movie it's you know 20 years old but he
ends up winning because of a computer
glitch
so new electronic voting machines are
brought in
and there's a glitch which causes him to
win it's the weirdest thing ever
just like watching this movie now the
weird the craziest thing about it is it
ends
with like he wins the presidency then it
ends with him realizing he didn't really
win
he goes on saturday night live and he's
like the establishment should be in
charge
we should allow the political elites who
have no allegiance to the american
people but like he says it seriously
the whole point of the movie is him
saying the republican part and the
democratic party represent us anymore
that they're just in it for the special
interest they take all this money then
they owe favors these to these interests
and they pay him back by screwing over
the little guy and ignoring what the
people need
and at the end he's like but you know
what maybe that's how it should be and
then they all cheer and celebrate and
center it live is like yay
it's really it's a really creepy movie
wow super creepy
yeah just you should check it out thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you